the rams lost in ugly fashioned dallas
cowboys 44 to 21
475 yards of offense for the cowboys and
look it's not hard to figure out
what it takes to beat the rams shut down
todd gurley yeah jared goff can't beat
you right and as the rams get closer and
closer to that off-season decision with
gurley of 10 and a half million that
would be fully guaranteed
beyond
whatever already guaranteed he otherwise
has i can't imagine them keeping him
around they need a todd gurley they just
can't count on todd gurley to be todd
gurley they got to find another todd
gurley good luck with that yeah good
luck with that is exactly right and uh
yeah the the cowboys played phenomenal i
mean they really they dominated the
football game there's no other way to
say it not only the run game but really
recently with the rams the game started
with boo legs and boo legs and screens
and things like that and then they went
to the run game and the cowboys never
let that get off and then to your point
yes when that's taken away and then
gurley can't run goff is just not the
type of guy and that offense within the
drop back pass offense is just not the
type of offense where he's going to
carry it it's just not and you know the
cowboys not only the defense that it
played great but the offense i mean come
on let me make sure i get this straight
but two out of the first three drives of
the football game the first drive of the
game for the cowboys was 15 plays 90
yards 600 i mean 6 minutes and 21 second
drive okay let they get a three-ply
75-yard drive to go up 14-7 and then the
very next drive they get pinned down
there by a good punt by the rams and go
14 plays 97 yards for a touchdown that
just takes the soul out of a football
team when you can
you know control the clock like that and
just dominate the line of scrimmage in
five yards and 10 yards and 12 yards and
four yards uh it just shows you're
physically dominating the football game
and they did from get go last thing i
want to i mean last thing i didn't mean
to go over a long answer here whatever
you're making it longer but i'm not
going to say that but i just thought it
didn't mean to make it that much longer
by saying that and there we go
now much longer by saying that ezekiel
elliott it was the best i saw him look
all year i don't give a damn about the
stats it was like he was twitchy and
quick and stop this like i'm gonna go
slow to the line of scrimmage and figure
out i mean he to me looked like a
different guy now their run game was
kicking butt and i get that and pollard
kicked some butt towards the end of the
game but man ezekiel elliott i thought
looked like the ezekiel elliot i
remember from year one and early year
two
elliott had 117 rushing yards on 24
carries pollard 131 on only 12. the rams
had 22 total rushing yards for the game
and
jared goff looked kind of out of sorts
early you can you can kind of get a a
sense from his demeanor if he's nervous
right right and when you get pressure up
the middle
any pressure up the middle around the
sides whatever
if goff does not have
gurley to either hand the ball off to or
throw those quick passes too it just
they they never get into a real no they
don't and and for as good as they had
looked after getting blown off the field
by the ravens here they are getting
blown off the field again just three
weeks later and now they need to win
their final two they go to san francisco
on saturday night they need the vikings
to lose two games at home the vikings
haven't lost at home all year they need
the vikings to lose two games at home
against the packers and the bears or the
rams will not be back in the playoffs
yeah um and you know again i don't know
if really they've played consistently at
the level the teams that are in the
playoffs right now other than the dallas
cowboys and of course dallas played one
of their best games of the year la
yesterday and and the other thing is i
just think it shows us you know we've
had this conversation a lot the last few
weeks dallas you can see when they put
the game together the right way
they are a special football team they
have spectra
special you know traits as far as just
you know again they're they're they're
so talented they're capable of
dominating the line of scrimmage on both
sides of the ball like we saw yesterday
they're phenomenal in the secondary you
know they got great receivers and
weapons on offense and dak prescott and
all that so you know even them and
overall complaining they might go into
the playoffs here at eight and eight or
nine and seven they're dangerous because
their talent level and performances like
yesterday show you they're capable of
really messing with anybody in the in
the league no matter how good that team
is as i pointed out last monday night
during the eagles giants game when new
york was up 17-3 after one half one of
these crap teams in the nfc east is
going to win the division host a playoff
game and beat the 49ers of the seahawks
and the good news for the eagles and the
cowboys they didn't look like crap teams
yesterday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports